my dad has a baseball signed by some
lady but I lady ho baby something or
other but I left it I left it my team
ho baby ho Wenberg I get a joke about
the Lindbergh baby I'm not okay I'm
proud of myself now I let my I let my my
my neighbourhood team that I was playing
with play with it and unfortunately you
know leave it to the rocket he hit a
home run and the [ __ ] beast in the
yard across the Sandlot gets it you
gotta get that ball back that's what
we're doing right after the show I'm
gonna spend the weekend try and get it
in break into James Earl Jones houses
kick the [ __ ] out of him if I can't get
my ball back everybody my dog has the
ball this is now my ball go away that
ball belongs to my dog not lost it not
be returned yeah I do a great change I
want three contests non-secure all right
I mean you deserve all the accolades and
awards you receive for that way to go
all right that was uh Oh in exactly two
minutes yeah tickets are on see I'm
gonna wear ha ha ha calm and July 27
tickets and the here's the promo for the
pre-sale jfl at Mt
just four last Montreal jfl MTL for July
the 27th on sale in 90 second one sell
go quickly and purchase yeah so you want
to see me yeah we're gonna be up there
broadcast instantly a fun week it's
gonna be a really fun week you can do
James Earl Jones on stage I'm gonna do
the entire radio show up there James
Earl Jones in the Sandlot only welcome
to Montreal same venues last year yeah
probably it was a great game I have a
baseball yes signed by the whole tiers
the entire team signed it watch them do
it it was not stamped can I add that
ball no my dog has your ball and you'll
not get it the great kings of the past I
can't hear it down on us from those dogs
[Laughter]
a lot was on two days ago and it's my
ruined dog your mother is with us hey
can I get that baseball back no no my
dog has your balls wait wait how about
okay all right just ruin it why don't
you one great thing you need to ruin it
with that character okay um I'm a lawyer
I am a lion I'm old go to the bathroom
outdoors forgive me young Simba I be
[ __ ] yes I'm old and I [ __ ] my pants
I have Duty caked in my fur not that old
you got killed I mean that's the whole
thing you got killed before you got old
wife duty in your first
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]